well let's start some controversy who's
the greatest chess player of all time
uh is it magnus carlsen is the gear
caspar visit uh somebody else bobby
fisher
do you have a favorite alex
so whenever i hear this question i
interpret it in a very specific way
where it's not
who was the most talented chess player
or who had the most impact on the chess
world but who is the greatest at playing
chess where if you were putting all of
these players at their peak who would be
the best
and you know we're kind of living
in a world where obviously humans are
becoming more like cyborgs and their
tools make them a lot more powerful
yes um and
the computer is the most powerful tool
for chess that we've ever witnessed and
the top players now someone like magnus
carlson or gary kasparov if they were
going to go towards people like you know
even lasker or bobby fisher back in the
day
lasker he was world champion for 27
years he was the best in his field by
far but would he be able to stand up to
someone like magnus carlson who has had
these tools i don't think so
so
most chess players have said gary
kasparov
and i think even magnus has said that in
the past but i like to think of it as
magnus in his peak and gary at his peak
and because magnus was able to live more
in a computer era i feel like so far
he's the greatest of all time and some
studies say things like how there's
rating inflation but i looked into some
of them and they basically calculated
people's
play in over the years and it seems that
there hasn't been inflation people are
just getting better and i think it's
because you have better tools at chess
and also the one one of the cases wait
what's your
i was going to say i actually i i
disagree with that
good make it interesting
i think i would judge the greatest like
greatest player of all time
in relative to the time that they lived
in and magnus although he is technically
the strongest chess player in history
that is because he had computers to
study chess with and of course
if you compare him to like gary kasparov
he plays most like stockfish but gary
kasparov at his time he beat more
players of his skill level than magnus
did magnus loses more often he also of
course held the belt for 20 years more
so i'd say actually because gary lacked
the help of computers to study chess and
overall performed better against
players of his skill level i think he
would be number one
nice
yeah but i mean the case that people
make for magnus
uh on many
i mean what alex said but but also
magnus plays a lot
and he doesn't
he plays a lot blitz bullet and
like he puts
he gets drunk and like he's really
putting himself out
and in all kinds of conditions and he's
able to dominate in a lot of them we get
to see many of the like losses and
blunders and all that kind of stuff
because he just puts himself out there
and i think uh caspar was much more like
never saw him play drunk right yeah
and it's very focused on the world
championship it's very
like
a very limited number of games and very
focused on winning and so
there's some aspect to the versatility
the aggressive play the fun the all of
that
that i think you have to give credit to
100
in terms of just the
the the scope
the scale of the variety of genius
exhibited by magnus and he might not
even be done yet i don't know if he'll
ever hit 2 900 but we can't judge
yet because he's not at the peak of his
career potentially what do you think
about him not playing world championship
isn't that like isn't that wild the
entirety of the history of chess in the
20th century going like meh
it's walking away from this one
tournament that's
seems to be at the center of chess
um what do you think about that decision
i mean you can't help but be
disappointed as a chess fan who wants to
see the best player in the world defend
his title
but i also understand it on a personal
level and not feeling as satisfied when
you're
going to the world championship and have
to having to defend against people who
are
less strong than you and also imagine
winning world championships and not
feeling a joy out of that
yeah so maybe by not doing that and
focusing instead on a goal like 2 900
he'll be more likely to accomplish it
because he's focusing on
what actually motivates him to play
chess but i do think that it will
hurt how we judge the next world
champion
i think it won't change him being the
best player in the world
and for someone to replace him even
let's say like nepo versus sting even if
one of them win and right and some
stance it does lower the merit because
now who has the world chess championship
title isn't actually the best player in
the world and that has happened before
in the past but still gonna take him
the same effort to prove when they would
pass him like 10 20 years to become
stronger than magnus so i don't think it
changes the skill level that it takes to
become the best chess player in the
world i think for chess fans it's very
disappointing but i think in the overall
like grand scheme of like the public
view to people who don't really
so like you know what breaks the popular
culture
and you think of what names people know
who don't play chess like bobby fischer
did it most people know casper over
magnus it takes the same ability and
talent and that doesn't change i think
it does change though if you're playing
a player who's not as strong
but i i see your point as well and i
know we differ on this like i heard you
asked magnus but what is your take on it
well
listen his answer is kind of brilliant
which
he's not saying he's he's bored of the
world championship he's
bored of a process that doesn't
determine the best player
like and it's too anxiety-inducing to
him to have a small number of games
he's he's
he doesn't mind losing which is really
fascinating to a better player right
or somebody who's his level he's more
anxious about losing
to um
a weaker player the weaker player
because of the small sample size now if
like poker players had that anxiety they
would never play at all right that's the
world series of poker you
you get to lose against weaker players
all the time that's the throw of the
dice but
that's an interesting perspective that
he would love to play 20 30 40 games
in the world championship but then he
would enjoy it much more and also play
shorter games because they
emphasize the um like pure chess
actually being able to
like
like much more variety in the middle
game just to see a bunch of chaos and
see how you're able to compute calculate
and intuition all that kind of stuff and
yeah that's beautiful
i wish the chess world would step up and
meet him in a place that makes sense
you know change the world championship
so feed it changing it somehow that a
loss for that
or having other really respected
tournaments that become like an annual
thing that step up to that
or more kind of
online youtube type of competitions
which i think they're trying to do more
and more like the crypto cup and all
those kinds of things yeah and the grand
tour the graduate does play in which
takes a lot of the top players and they
do it online in shorter formats
but there's you know and so that's his
perspective my
perhaps narrow perspective as i
romanticize the olympic games and those
are every four years and the
and the world championships
because they're rare because the sample
size is so small that's where the magic
happens everything's on the line for you
know for people that spend their whole
life
20 years of dedication
everything you have every minute of the
day is spent for that moment you know
you think about like gymnastics at the
olympic games there's certain sports
where a single mistake and you're [ __ ]
and that stress that pressure
it can
it can um
it can break people or it can create
magic
like a person that's the underdog
has the best night of their life or the
person that's been dominating for years
all of a sudden slips up and that drama
from a human perspective is beautiful so
i still like the world championships but
then again
looking at all the draws
looking at like
well
the magic isn't quite there
so to me when i see faster games of
chess that's much more
that's much more beautiful so but that i
don't understand the game of chess
deeply enough to know
like does it have to be so um
so many draws
like is there a way to create a more
dynamic chess and he talked about random
chess like with a random starting
position that's really interesting but
then of course that
that's like then you do have to play
hundreds of games and that kind of stuff
right uh so i but i think
it's great that the world number one
is um
struggling with these questions
because he's in the position he has the
leverage to actually change the game of
chess
as it's publicly seen as publicly played
so it's um it's interesting he's still
young enough to to dominate for quite a
long time if he wants
so i don't know i you know i do with
kasparov the the the fight between
nations i i hope these have the world
championship and i hope there's a
i hope he's still part of it somehow
i hope he changes his mind
and comes back comes back some kind of
dramatic thing i don't know
but it is it is his heart is not in it
and then
um
and then that's not beautiful to see
right
uh
yeah it is beautiful
that the thing he wants is a great game
of chess against an opponent that's his
level or better
and that's that's great that he's coming
from that place but i hope he comes back
tomorrow because the the world
championship is uh is a special thing in
any sport
so you do wish that the person who wins
the world championship is the best
player in the world
no
i hope that the best people in the world
the two best people in the world are the
ones that sit down
but the person that wins is the person
that that that's the magic of it nobody
knows who's going to win i think magnus
is so
he he really wants the best person to
win like the the
that's why he wants the large sample
size but to me there's some magic to it
the the stress of it the the drama of it
that's all part of the game like it's
not just about the purity of the game
like the the calculation
the pure chest of it it's also like the
drama
like
the yeah the the pressure the drama all
of it
the [ __ ] talking if it gets to you the
mind games yeah this is the part that's
fun to watch but less fun to be playing
to beat but that's why it's great who
can melt who can rise under that
pressure and who melts under that
pressure
you